I love you Wade Wilson we can fight this
you're right the cancer is only my liver
lungs prostate and brain all things I
can live without what if I told you we
can make you better
you're a fighter we can give you
abilities most men only dream of make
you a superhero would you just promise
you'll do right by me so I could do
right by someone else and please don't
make the supersuit green or animated one
thing that never survives this place
it's a sense of humor
we'll see about that posh spice oh come
on you know leave me all alone here with
less angry Rosie O'Donnell I wanna thank
your mother for her [ __ ]
No
right you may be wondering why the red
suit well that's so bad guys can't see
me bleed this guy's got the right idea
he wore the brown pants killer music
Rick's like old lady pants in here was
such a douche this morning oh you are
hard to look at you look like the
topographical map of Utah
exactly
oh I am very turned on right now
you are look like an avocado had sex
with an older avocado thank you